what I want to do in this video is think
about how exchange rates can affect
trade and actually we can even think a
little bit about how they might be able
to affect each other although we'll go
into a lot more depth in that in future
videos so let's just imagine a situation
where the Chinese Wan Chinese Wan
depreciates versus the dollar
depreciates versus the US dollar to be
clear US dollar and to visualize what
we're talking about let's draw the
supply and demand or the exchange market
for the Chinese one so our horizontal
axis would be quantity quantity of one
and then our vertical axis would be the
price of one in terms of dollars so
dollars per one and we've seen this
before
this right here would be the supply of
Juan so these would be the people who
are holding Juan but might be willing to
exchange them into dollars and then this
would be the demand for one these are
the people who are holding dollars who
might be interested in exchanging them
for one and there will be some
equilibrium exchange rate let's call
that C sub one and let's call this and
some equilibrium quantity per time
period let's say it's call that Q sub
one and just to be clear this is our
supply curve for the one and this is our
demand curve for the one and so a
situation where the Chinese wan
depreciates versus the dollar there's
two ways really that that could happen
one you could have the demand for the
wan shift to the left
or you could have the supply of wan
shift to the right the demand shifting
to the left would mean for some reason
people who hold dollars are less
interested in getting wan and supply
shifting to the right would mean people
who old Wan are all of a sudden more
interested in getting dollars so
actually let's just do the latter one so
let's say the supply shifts to the right
I just want a scenario where we have the
Chinese wan depreciating against the
US dollar and so you see very clearly in
this world if our demand it does not
shift we get to this next equilibrium
exchange rate a sub two and there's also
a different equilibrium quantity but you
can see the Chinese want has depreciated
versus a dollar if East sub 1 maybe East
sub 1 is 15 cents per Chinese wan and
maybe e sub 2 is 10 cents per Chinese
one but now we oughtn't that we
understand we can visualize what we're
talking about what would be the impact
on trade and I'm going to think about it
in two ways what is going to happen in
China let's think about China first so
in China or we're gonna be thinking
about the Chinese consumers well Chinese
consumers they hold one and they might
buy some American goods and what would
happen to the cost of those American
goods well assuming that the American
suppliers offer their products in a
fixed dollar price so let's say you are
General Motors an American car company
and there's a car that's manufactured
the United States and it costs 20
thousand dollars well in a world where
the Chinese wond appreciates versus the
dollar the amount of wan to equal 20
thousand US dollars has now increased
you need more one per dollar because
you're in a world where there's fewer
dollars per wan so American goods
American goods more expensive in China I
expensive in China and so what would
might that do to the behavior how might
people decide to trade-off between
American and Chinese let's say in this
example cars
well if American goods in this example
car has become relatively more expensive
then they're likely to buy fewer
American cars and so if we're talking
about all American products we could say
American American imports into China
into China will go down because they're
going to be relatively more expensive
now what about in the
United States in the United States what
is going to happen well assuming that
Chinese goods are offered by the
supplier at a fixed Wan price well now
you need fewer dollars per wan so
Chinese goods Chinese goods are going to
be less expensive less expensive to
American buyers so less expensive in the
US because each dollar is going to buy
more Wan and assuming to the goods or
have a fixed price in wine and so you
could say Chinese imports into imports
into the US are going to go up and
what's interesting is that you might
have a little bit of a negative
self-correcting feedback loop because
what's likely to happen if American
imports into China go down well that
means that fewer Chinese folks are going
to be interested in converting their wan
into US dollars in order to buy goods
because they're not buying as many
American goods and so that might have
the effect of shipping shifting the
supply curve back to the left
similarly in a world where Chinese
imports in the United States go up well
now all of a sudden more Americans will
be interested in converting their
dollars into wan and so that might shift
the demand curve to the right and so
that might either of these could have
the effect of maybe helping the Chinese
Wan appreciate a bit now in previous
videos we've talked about many factors
that could shift the supply or demand
curve for a currency to the right or the
left but it would be interesting to
think about what would be the effects of
interest rate changes in each country
and now we can link it not just to what
would happen to the supply and demand
curve but we could think about how that
might affect trade let's imagine a
situation where the US government
government increases borrowing and we've
talked about this in previous videos
that will likely lead to increased
interest rates because you'd have a big
borrower here you could even have a
crowding out effect because of the
increased interest rates fewer private
borrowers in the u.s. might borrow but
this would increase
likely doesn't always increase interest
rates interest rates in the US now if
you have increased rates in the US what
might happen for folks in China well
they might say hey we are more
interested in holding dollars because we
could in a dollar a bank account all of
a sudden we get more interest and so
that could have the effect that we saw
earlier where it could say hey more Wan
holders are interested in converting
into the US dollars so it would shift
the supply of wan to the right which
would have the impact of depreciating
the chinese wand which is where we
started this video and so you could see
something like the US government
borrowing which increases interest rates
can actually have an impact on trade it
could actually make American Goods less
competitive in China and Chinese Goods
more competitive in the United States
and I just did a scenario where the
supply curve shifts to the right but you
could also imagine a situation where
government borrowing increasing the
interest rate in the United States could
even change the demand curve remember
the demand curves going to be determined
by the sentiment from dollar holders and
how much they want to convert to the wan
but if interest rates in the United
States go up well now they might say hey
I might want to save in the United
States as opposed to investing in China
or converting my money to wan and saving
in chinese bank accounts so I'll leave
you there the big thing to appreciate
here is that exchange rates and trade
are very linked and that things like
government borrowing can affect interest
rates which can affect exchange rates
which can affect trade